[Applaus]
si
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dank
sie zeigen
die darf
jeder hinsicht ein ja und herzlich
willkommen auch ihnen zu hause schön
sind sie dabei legislative judikative
exekutive die gewaltentrennung gilt
vielen als einer der zentralen säulen
unserer demokratie schon jean jacques
rousseau hat allerdings steven drei
gewalten eine vierte an die seite
gestellt nämlich die medien die frage
ist bloss können die medien so etwas
sein wie eine publica tiven und vor
allem heute welche rolle kommt den
medien eigentlich in unserer
gesellschaft in unserer demokratie zu
das ist unser thema heute am
philosophischen stammtisch fakt ist auf
jeden fall die medien sind weltweit
massiv unter druck
und zwar gleich aus ganz verschiedenen
richtungen nicht nur in der türkei ist
es für journalisten gefährlich geworden
ihren job unabhängig und stars kritisch
auszuüben
auch in ländern der eu steht es nicht
zum besten
trotz protesten der bevölkerung baut zum
beispiel ungarns ministerpräsident
viktor orban seine machtposition
sukzessive aus so dass er kritische
medien zu verstummen bringen kann
jüngster und bedenklichsten höhepunkt in
diesem zusammenhang die ermordung des
slowakischen enthüllungsjournalisten jan
kozak und seiner verlobten martin
akkuschrauber der 29-jährige stand kurz
vor der veröffentlichung seiner
recherche die mögliche verbindungen
zwischen slowakischen politikern und der
kalabrischen mafia aufdeckte weniger
drastisch aber in seiner tendenz doch
alarmierend donald trumps angriff auf
die pressefreiheit in dem er gewissen
medien pauschal und undifferenziert die
produktion von fake news vorwirft machte
sich zum totengräber der freien
meinungsäußerung nicht nur die privaten
medien stehen unter druck
auch die öffentlichen bekanntlich haben
71,6 prozent des schweizer stimmvolks
die sogenannte no ballack initiative
abgelehnt
doch die diskussion um den service
publique ist damit noch lange nicht
abgeschlossen
bezeichnend dass diese abstimmung auch
im benachbarten ausland auf interesse
gestoßen ist großer mehrheit haben sich
die schweizer für die beibehaltung der
rundfunkgebühren ausgesprochen
die schweizer haben mit deutlicher
mehrheit gegen die abschaffung der
rundfunkgebühr gestimmt diese initiative
ist gescheitert und zwar deutlicher als
erwartet nach dem klaren volksentscheid
in der schweiz hofft der orf dass der
druck etwas nachlässt die zeitung
österreich titelt heute sogar schweizer
retten orf gebühren ja die medien als 40
mal das diskutieren wir heute ich bin
sehr gespannt begrüßen sie ganz herzlich
mit mir unsere stammgäste sind vier
philosophen die zugleich die
medienlandschaft von innen kennen
kathrin newmark kulturjournalistin aus
berlin
daniel binswanger vom onlinemagazin die
republik norbert bolz professor für
medienwissenschaften an der tu in berlin
und keine scheu chef des fcz fans ganz
herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
wir haben es gehört die medien sind
massiv unter druck sind sie auch als
vierte gewalt in frage gestellt also ist
es offensichtlich dass es leute gibt die
sie in frage stellen die rolle der
klassischen kritischen medien die
sozusagen den reichen und mächtigen auf
die finger schauen in frage stellen ist
aber auch die frage wer das normativ
oder deshalb die verstehen also normativ
müsste man dann sagen die vierte gewalt
ist nötiger denn je gerade in dem moment
wo sie angegriffen wird des kreativ muss
man sagen ist sie natürlich überhaupt
nicht in frage gestellt denn was ist
anderes als medien alles was wir
heutzutage in der öffentlichkeit tun
also noch viel mehr als zum beispiel
herr sloterdijk kürzlich in einem sehr
schönen interview mit den kollegen scheu
gesagt hat also auch schon der antike
marktplatz ist in gewisser weise ein
medialer raum das volks radio mehr sagte
er glaube ich was ich sehr schön fand
aber gleichzeitig heutzutage sind wir
noch viel stärker auf medien angewiesen
für die sache der demokratie der
öffentlichkeit also wir haben diesen
marktplatz ja kaum mehr alles was wir
heutzutage in der öffentlichkeit machen
ist medial vermittelt gerade durch den
aufstieg der sozialen netzwerke und da
ist es ganz klar hat dieser bereich in
dem demokratie ausgehandelt wird ist in
einer massiven weise medial das ist es
kreativ überhaupt nicht in frage zu
stellen die frage ist wie wir damit
umgehen
na gut aber jetzt haben sie sozusagen
schon über die neuen medien gesprochen
können diese neuen medien sozusagen
diese lücke füllen können die neuen
medien die vierte gewalt wehren erbin
sagen nein selbstverständlich nicht die
neuen medien werden
wandeln das medium umfeld sehr stark sie
leisten einen wichtigen beitrag aber sie
können die klassischen medien nicht
ersetzen
allerdings möchte ich auch darauf
hinweisen dass natürlich die kritik an
den medien und die frage was ist die
vierte gewalt ist illegitim kann sie ihr
amt ausüben so alt ist wie die theorie
der vierten gewalt und zwar angefangen
bei rousseau selber eher schlicht ja
nicht von medien er spricht von opinio
publik also der öffentlichen meinung und
er hat der öffentlichen meinung
gegenüber ein sehr sehr ambivalentes
verhältnis im
sozial ist die öffentliche meinung wird
so gewissermaßen zwar
zivilgesellschaftlichen äquivalent des
allgemein willens also man sagt es auch
nicht nur gerechte gesetzes auch in der
gesellschaft an verständnis braucht die
tugenden und dem moralkodex der dem
entspricht und das muss die öffentliche
meinung regeln spricht ja vom der
öffentlichen meinung aus zehn zwar aber
es steht den medien schon sehr kritisch
gegenüber was überall in seinem werk
immer wieder auftaucht ganz besonders
beispielsweise in dem brief an thailand
und das problem dass rosso hat ist ja
dass ein grundzug seines denkens der
durchgeht und das ist etwas was wir
heute wieder kehren sehen ist die
tatsache dass er denkt solange der
mensch natürlich ist solange er von der
zivilisation nicht korrumpiert wird
solange er in seiner naiven unschuld
belassen wird solange wer tugendhaft
sein und das richtige tun und da
erscheinen die medien bzw die opinio
belegt dann plötzlich als der große
feind und das ist ein phantasma dass ihr
zurückweisen müssen und dass heute
wieder hochkonjunktur hat gerade eben
das ausdrückt wenn nur der volkswille
sich manifestieren könnte wenn nur die
meinung so legten das volk nicht
unterdrücken würden wenn es nicht diese
großen bösartigen manipulations macht
die nationen gäbe dann würde in reiner
natürlichkeit und spontaneität das volk
das richtige sei das ein ganz ganz
großer teil davon ist ohne begleitet uns
seit dem beginn der moderne und ihre
these wäre es braucht diese vierte
gewalt weil wir eben nicht im
naturzustand leben nicht ich habe
natürlich vollkommener unsinn
das ist natürlich vollkommener unsinn
wie soll denn ein voll eine zu einem
klugen ein schal kommen wenn es über die
informationen gar nicht verfügt und wie
soll es an die informationen kommen
wenn wir ein gutes mediensystem haben er
schaue jetzt schon ganz unruhig kann man
so sehen ja ich halte diese rede von der
vierten gewalt soderbergh zu zurückgehen
für sehr problematisch
also wir haben dann eben sie haben es
erwähnt die exekutive legislative und
judikative und dann die publica tiefe es
wird so suggeriert als wäre das
sozusagen die vierte gewalt im staate
ich denke medien gerade heute sollten
sich durch staatsferne auszeichnen also
medien sind erfüllen keinen staatlichen
auftrags und sind sie viel
gesellschaftliche akteure die in der
öffentlichen sphäre handeln uns die
öffentliche sphäre die ist immer schon
gegeben jeder das ist ein wort erhebt
und sich an ein anonymes sozusagen
potenziell unendliches publikum wendet
macht sozusagen öffentlichen gebrauch
von seiner vernunft und ich finde diese
staatsnahe die diese rede von der
vierten gewalt suggeriert wirklich
höchst problematisch gerade heute ich
stelle mir das vollkommen zu ich glaube
in der tat ist das eine fehlleitung wenn
man meint man könnte gewissermaßen auf
gleicher ebene legislative exekutive
jurisdiktionen und dann auch noch die
presse oder die öffentlichen medien
ansetzen sie müssten ein ganz anderes
selbstverständnis haben und das hatten
sie ursprünglich auch nämlich
tatsächlich in ihrer konstitution also
ich bin wirklich kein anhänger von
jürgen habermas aber seine
habilitationsschrift ist nach wie vor
interessant
die heißt strukturwandel der
öffentlichkeit und erzählt sehr schön
die geschichte der entwicklung der
öffentlichkeit und zwar wie sich das
bürgertum heraus entwickelt aus dieser
befangenheit in den vorquartalen welt
und der feudalen repräsentations welt
und da geht es um das vollkommen
autonome bürgerliche ressort die bürger
unterhalten sich untereinander also das
ist gesellschaftlich und nicht staatlich
und das ermöglicht oder hat sollte
einmal ermöglichen eine wirklich
souveräne kritik des staates und aller
staatlichen organe und insofern denke
ich hatte schon das zentrum des problems
getroffen
ich glaube nämlich dass das was sie
reden im einspieler gesehen haben
an bedrohung des der vierten gewalt
presse und medien im grunde nur
trivialitäten sind da braucht man kein
philosoph den stammtisch einfach deshalb
weil jeder normale mensch sofort sagt
putin erdogan trump das ist alles
katastrophal das ist eine
fehlentwicklung dagegen müssen wir
kämpfen
dazu brauchen sie keinen philosophen um
das herauszufinden das problem steckt
anderswo und das ist das was wenn ich
ein recht verstanden habe wohl gemeint
hat nämlich dass in den letzten
jahrzehnten tatsächlich in vielen vielen
gerade echt demokratischen ländern die
presse ein anderes selbstverständnis
entwickelt hat nämlich nicht mehr das
selbstverständnis der kritischen instanz
gegenüber dem staat und seinen organen
sondern dass es zu einer art kooperation
und koordinierung zwischen politik und
medienvertretern gerade den großen
derlei sogenannten leitmedien gekommen
das ist ein echtes beispiel dafür ja es
gibt eine sehr schöne kontroverse in
deutschland darüber ob über die inhalte
berichtet werden müsste wenn sich
führende regierungsvertreter mit
führenden journalisten treffen zu
gesprächen das muss zwar veröffentlicht
werden dass sie sich treffen daran gibt
es keinen zweifel
aber es muss nicht darüber berichtet
werden was da geredet wird und es gibt
also diese absprachen es gibt diese
koordination von politik und großem
medien- und mein lieblingsbeispiel ist
ich hoffe das klingt nicht allzu
polemischer deutsches beispiel ist für
sich ja ganz unverfänglich wenn sich
beispielsweise das heute-journal ansehen
haben sie das gefühl das ist regierungs
fernsehen ich würde gerne widerspruch
anmelden zu diesem doch zwei leicht
unterschiedliche wir sind hier am
stammtisch
ich glaube das problem liegt hier in dem
verständnis dessen was start ist wenn
sie staatsferne
dann gehen sie davon aus dass der staat
in irgendeiner weise manipulativ
machtvoll aber auf jeden fall feindselig
sei das ist sozusagen die eine idee die
im moment wahnsinnig viel aufschwung
auch hat die dieses liberale bis
libertärer idee dass der staat in
irgendeiner weise hampel problematisch
sei und wenn man jetzt aber von der
vierten gewalt sozusagen in diesen
ursprünglichen demokratie theoretischen
debatten redet dann redet man doch
eigentlich darüber dass der staat das
sind wir der souverän das ist der bürger
das heißt man hat gewisse organe die man
beauftragt mit dingen die zu erledigen
sind jemand muss diese
regierungsgeschäfte leiten wir wählen
repräsentanten ins repräsentantenhaus
der stadt sind in diesem sinne wie und
in einer funktionierenden demokratie
sind wir sowohl der staat als wir auch
die medien sind wir beauftragen nämlich
auch indem wir das auch bezahlen sei es
über eine gebühr sei es indem wir eine
zeitung abonnieren
wir beauftragen jemanden öffentliche
diskussionen zu führen über das
gemeinwohl und ich glaube hier muss man
vielleicht einfach unterscheiden reden
wir von medien in einer funktionierenden
demokratie oder reden wir von medien in
diktaturen wo sie natürlich diese
gegenüberstellung wo sie diese andere
position einnehmen müsse sich das
kritische unter lebensgefahr
recherchieren von allem was schief läuft
aber ich glaube und da muss man eben in
diesen diese zwei fälle unterscheiden
und da ist auch ein anderer staats
begriff weil dieses anmahnen von
staatsferne
das ist so beliebt geworden und das
macht überhaupt keinen sinn wenn wir
demokratietheoretisch davon ausgehen
dass wir in guest wird dass der staat
das von uns bestellte gemeinwesen es
steht hier gerne ein zitat von herrn
dienstwagen einen bringen er hat die
märz in der republik geschrieben die
kontrolle über die medien die liiert zum
zentralen kampffeld um die zukunft der
demokratie also da scheinen ja die
medien und die demokratie unglaublich
eng verzahnt zu sein der die medien
kontrolliert kontrolliert ein stück weit
die politik ja wir sehen das ja allen
taten
das scheint mir einigermaßen evident ich
möchte aber noch auf meine vorredner
ich glaube dass wir die problematik noch
einmal etwas tiefer legen westerwelle
als sie das getan haben denn das
problematisch nichts staatsnähe oder
staatsferne ich kann mich ihnen hier nur
anschluss schließen also diese amt
etatismus fixierung die glaubt dass
jedes problem in der nur unter dem
gesichtspunkt staatlich gar nicht
staatlichkeit zu betrachten ist ja
scheint mir einfach grenzenlos naiv es
ist nicht ein problem von staaten nicht
schaut es ist ein problem der macht und
nicht nur staaten üben macht aus das
problem mit dem ansatz der vierten
gewalt ist es geht ja nicht um gewalt im
buchstäblichen sinn wir reden von den
drei gebauten von der gewaltenteilung es
geht ja darum im machtsystem system die
ausübung von gewalt zu verhindern also
ist sind die medien ein machtsystem und
nein das sind sie nicht
nicht wenn wir wenn wir zu einer kritik
oder wenn wir zur kritik der propaganda
funktion der medien geraten kommen
wollen dann kommt es nicht darauf an
obis milliardäre sind die sich medien
zusammen kaufen oder ob es die
staatsgewalt ist die die medien
kontrolliert oder ob es dunkle
politische kräfte sind die hinter den
kulissen die fäden ziehen sondern es
kommt darauf an verstehen die medien
sich als reines machtsystem oder sehen
sie ihren auftrag auch noch als einen
abend raten
und natürlich ist die eigentliche
verpflichtung der medien die
demokratiepolitische verpflichtungen und
der medien an aufklärerischer und
solange die medien ihren aufklärerischen
auftrag ernst nehmen und der wahrheit
verpflichtet sind und nicht einfach so
lange sie nach bestem wissen und
gewissen und das ist immer schwierig und
im relativ und im abba aber sagen sie
diesen auftrag wahrnehmen solange
üben sie eine kontrollfunktion aus und
sind tatsächlich in einem gewissen der
relativen sinne die vierte gewalt genau
in dem maße wie sie eben nicht
binswangen sie haben gesagt es sei naiv
wenn man sozusagen einen begriff pflege
der davon ausgeht dass der staat macht
kumuliert ich würde sagen es gibt keine
instanz die keine instanz kein apparat
der macht stärker zentralisiert aus der
stadt also ich finde es naiv sozusagen
zu unterstellen staatsferne ist
eigentlich notwendig um journalistisch
aufklärerisch tätig zu sein also
selbstverständlich ist das so aber das
heißt ja nicht wenn man von staatsferne
spricht dass man deswegen ein star ist
so das ist eine gleichsetzung die ich
auch von mir weisen würde ich denke aber
wir reduzieren die diskussion medien
haben ja nicht nur die aufgabe
staatlicher akteure zu kritisieren oder
wirtschaftliche akteure zu kritisieren
sondern es geht auch darum dass man
themen setzt dass man den button
lanciert dass man die zukunft verhandelt
das sagen sie natürlich aus
ausbeuterischer liegen zu recht darf ich
aber trotzdem noch einmal auf diesen
punkt zeiten noch ein bisschen darauf
rumreiten also wir hatten jetzt wenn ich
sie richtig verstanden habe herr bolz
ihre these ware sind hier trivialitäten
obschon sie auch gesagt haben naja
eigentlich gibt's die unabhängigen
medien gar nicht die machen bei
irgendwelche abmachungen mit
regierungsvertretern und dann wird das
nicht einmal publik gemacht das nehme
ich jetzt mal an ist für sie ja keine
trivialität das genau darüber dass mich
das was mich fasziniert und was ich für
ein würdiges philosophisches thema halte
während die anderen dinge sind trivial
nicht im sinne von unwichtig sondern uns
im sinne von jedem sowieso evident
vielleicht darf ich das aber auch an
einem beispiel noch mal weil sie zu
recht ja gesagt haben bringen sie doch
mal ein beispiel 1 dass jeder sehr gut
nachprüfen kann ich das einfach nur
googelt
es gab das liegt natürlich schon einige
jahre zurück einen artikel im guardian
und wer den gar die nicht kennt das ist
das linke vorzeige die zwei also sowie
jemanden was weiß ich bei uns sich
süddeutsche lesen würde er oder früher
die fw die frankfurter rundschau
das ist der linke vorzeige zeitungen die
seriöse und im garten gab es diesen
fantastischen artikel government light
and i'm glad das war der kommentar also
die dass die regierung hat ihr das volk
angelogen und ich freue mich darüber
dass heißt es ging um das was man weise
lügen and white lies über die übrigens
platon schon faszinierend berichtet in
der polit er also die vorstellung der
guten menschen das ist immer gut gemeint
dass es keine bösartigkeit dahinter die
guten menschen denken
es täte dem volk hin und wieder gut wenn
man ihnen nicht die wahrheit sagt weil
sie weil das volk noch unbedarft ist und
unmündig ist und über reagiert da gibt
es bei uns natürlich eine fülle von
beispielen für solche themen wo sensible
journalisten und sensibles politiker
meinen man sollte das volk da vielleicht
nicht mit der kompletten wahrheit
konfrontieren wer weiß wie die darauf
reagieren und dieses problem der weißen
liegen würde ich sagen das ist das
kardinalproblem der westlichen
demokratie und jetzt haben sie noch
einen oben drauf gelegt das
kardinalproblem der westlichen
demokratie würde mich schon
interessieren das ja das stichwort
gesinnungs journalismus das ist also ein
stichwort das wir immer wieder bringen
sie sagen dass ethos der journalisten
ist und dass es schlecht bestellt es
gibt einen gesinnungsgenossen sie werden
hier dauernd umerzogen so ungefährlich
einzig haben und bringt dann halte ich
mich drei runden zurück
ein wunderbares versprechen versprochen
besser kann man es einfach nicht sagen
das war hanns joachim friedrichs einer
der großartigsten fernsehkommentatoren
die es im deutschen fernsehen gab und er
hat einmal gesagt ein journalist sollte
sich niemals mit irgendeiner sache
gemein machen auch nicht mit einer guten
und das finde ich das sagt alles was man
über journalismus wissen aber jetzt
können wir doch erst mal festhalten die
haben ja zum beispiel in der schweiz die
unterschiedlichsten medien also wenn sie
sagen es gibt ein gewinn
journalismus dann müssten wir auch davon
ausgehen irgend jemand kontrolliert die
ausrichtung der medien haben aber eine
sehr große pluralität wo liegt das
problem wenn wir eine pluralität an
medien haben wir haben an der pluralität
und ich denke die verdanken wir dem
privatwirtschaftlich organisierten
wettbewerb das ist aus konsumentensicht
sehr erfreulich also sozusagen die
zivilgesellschaftlichen akteure bewegen
sich in einem wettbewerb das ist schon
mal sehr gut ich würde aber wiederum ich
würde herrn scholz in seinem votum
unterstützen wir haben offensichtlich
ist einen kleinen graben und haben ganz
bewusst links gesehen und ich würde
sagen etwas was stimmte politiker einige
politiker viele politiker mit bestimmten
einigen vielen journalisten verbindet
ist eine pädagogische ader und
journalisten hantieren haben auch macht
es ist vielleicht einerseits macht sie
sind eher zahlungen gäste der macht aber
sie haben macht ist nämlich die macht
der sprache und sprache bild nicht nur
wirklichkeit ab sondern erschafft
wirklichkeit und wenn man einen
pädagogischen impetus hat und weiß dass
man über macht verfügt dann geschieht es
leicht dass man die leser sozusagen als
manipulierbare masse betrachter jeder
kann ja schreiben kann jeder einen blog
starten es gibt unterschiedliche medien
obwohl jeder journalist kann sich äußern
genau ich würde einfach sagen wir haben
schon eine art milieu getriebenen
journalismus auf wir haben gleichzeitig
auch ein bild moralismus und deswegen
ist die lage in der schweiz sehr gut wir
haben kein problem wir haben kein
problem
jetzt würde ich gerne wirklich nochmal
wissen müssen das problem sie haben am
anfang gesagt herr binswanger
katastrophe regen diesen begriff habe
ich gehört
jetzt rächen sie zu mir wie mein vater
da wirklich um wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich strecke ist wie ihr vater
gesagt dass ich versuchen die versuchte
sympathisch den verdacht zu formulieren
dass ich schon denn sie sagen nun naja
staatsferne wichtig aber da würde kein
staats hausherren spielen ob es um sind
sie der feuerteufel von einer zeitung
die auf dem höhepunkt des
abstimmungskampfes zur nobile ein text
veröffentlicht die schweiz braucht kein
staatsfernsehen
das war ihre ansage mich wundert dann
wissen dass wir heute haben wir
überhaupt hier setzen
denn offenbar braucht es das gar nicht
als ausrede ich mein texas war der text
von erika sie haben ein buch
herausgegeben und zwei tranchen diese
jugendtreff kerbe haut ja es waren sehr
sehr radikaler text ein ungeheurer
schatz weg machen das machen wir jetzt
hier
sechs wechsel da müsste ich jetzt
replizieren dass herr bin zwar den text
nicht genau gelesen hat wollte ich ihn
an sagt vorlesen nur ein einsatz ist zu
wenig die pointe ist ja dass er am ende
sagt es ist wichtig dass wir diese
diskussion führen das steht ja erst sagt
der anspruch der srg ist ich zitiere
totalität er sagt die srg ist total
nein das sagt ich will hier keinen text
vorgelesen ich würde gerne wissen warum
sind jetzt usa gekommen
wir waren ja bei der auch nicht das
beispiel war er jetzt also wir haben
darüber gesprochen wie schlimm ist das
ganze die beiden euren bürgermeinungen
war es ist alles bestens in der schweiz
sie sind der meinung nein ist es nicht
haben als beispiel die srg gebracht von
der herrscher glaubt in ihrem buch haben
sie es so geschrieben dass weniger
weniger staat gleich mehr fernsehen so
war der titel ist 2005 kunden
warum bringen sie dieses beispiel ich
bringe dieses beispiel weil sich eben
die frage stellt was
staatsferne und sich die frage stellt
das ist eine der großen fragen für die
medienpolitik der schweiz sind
staatliche medien überhaupt legitim und
ich habe den eindruck dass herr schauen
ganz genau diese position vertritt und
was mich ein bisschen irritiert dass er
diese position vertritt ohne es deutlich
sagen zu wollen und das finde ich dass
ich habe das gefühl ich war als sie
meinen wurden hinreichend deutlich
wollen wir jetzt über mein buch
debattieren nicht ich möchte gerne
wirklich das ja frauen stellten sie eine
frage ich würde einfach gerne noch mal
ganz kurz zu diesen verbindungen mit dem
start zurückkommen de herr bolz ihr
schon relativ ein paar worten zurück ich
weiß nicht ob schon drei runden
angewandt hat oder sich noch nicht sie
sehen ja in deutschland das massive
problem dass wenn sie zb was ard zdf
schauen sie das gefühl haben sie hören
regierungserklärungen
das halte ich tatsächlich für eine
verzerrte darstellung nicht nur weil mir
dieser eindruck nicht kommt wenn ich
diese sender schauen sondern tatsächlich
auch weil es liegt zumindest in
deutschland so scheint mir im
verständnis der medien und zwar nicht
nur der durch rundfunkgebühren irgendwie
finanzierten medien sondern aller medien
dass sie nicht nur debatten foren sind
die im luftleeren raum stehen sondern im
sinne des wortes medium vermittler sind
und gerade in deutschland hat das eine
ganz starke tradition dass man eben auch
vermitteln soll was passiert jetzt
gerade in der region was sind diese
internen debatten und das von der
arbeitsweise her es ist natürlich so
dass sie journalisten öfters mit diesen
politikern treffen als sie dann darüber
berichten also das ist nicht jedes
gespräch ist dann gleich als interview
veröffentlicht
es gibt ja eine gewisse personelle nähe
die aber wieder die journalisten der
öffentlich-rechtlichen noch der privat
finanzierten medien davon abhält
kritisch zu berichten darüber wenn sie
den eindruck haben dass etwas in der
regierung schief läuft also aber dass
dieses berichterstattung darüber was die
regierung gerade tut dass das noch nicht
ein propagandistischer arm der regierung
sein ist das sind diese unterscheidungen
müsste man schon auch noch trennen und
die gerade in deutschland ist dieses
verständnis dass man natürlich auch zu
eine berichterstattungspflicht hat
gerade weil ich aber in der schweiz
sagen wir in der schweiz aber vielleicht
möchten sie dazu noch kurz nach 23 uhr
ganz kurz es gibt gar keinen zweifel
daran erstens und das sage ich nicht um
die wogen zu glätten
dass es überall noch hervorragenden
journalismus gibt also gerade auch in
deutschland gibt es natürlich vor
großartige zeitungen auch ich muss wäre
ohne euch vermutlich schätze übrigens
dieser zeitung die offenbar nicht von
allen geschätzt ist sehr doch sie haben
alle lesen aber der entscheidende punkt
und das hat wiederum auch er schon
angesprochen ist der dass es um das
selbstverständnis des journalisten geht
das eben nicht nur dass das
selbstverständnis des vermittlers ist
und dass berichterstatters deshalb habe
ich vorhin jürgen habermas schöne bild
schrift noch mal ins spiel gebracht in
der das wirklich in aller naivität
genauso entwickelt wird die medien
vielfältigen nur oder sie sind nur
lautsprecher des gesprächs der bürger
untereinander wunderbare idee hat nur
mit der wirklichkeit nur noch am rande
zu tun
der entscheidende problematische punkt
ist genau der den sie mit gesinnungs
schon alles muss mich zitieren und
angesprochen haben und das heißt eben
und das entspricht durchaus dem
selbstverständnis sehr vieler zumindest
deutscher journalisten dass sie mehr
wollen als nur berichten sondern sie
wollen auch belehren und erziehen
also diese vorstellung relocation als
intellektuelle leistungszeit der 68er
bewegung die ist immer noch in vollem
gange und was nicht fasziniert berichtet
sagen da fast philosophisch fasziniert
ist wieso ausgerechnet die linken zur
staats verliebt sind das wundert mich
auch bei ihnen sie sind doch links
das habe ihr kennt das hat mal gesagt so
also ich halte aber gut eine ganz andere
debatte dass sich diese den nominationen
rechts und links nicht mehr für sinnvoll
halte in der heutigen welt aber das
debattieren wir beim nächsten haus das
trennten sich die schweiz aber wenn ich
die dem von ihnen bemängelten so seinen
pädagogischen impetus ja ich sehe wie
man darauf grantig reagieren kann ich
sie gleichzeitig aber auch ich glaube in
gewisser weise ähnlich wie der bündner
natürlich ist sind medien der wahrheit
verpflichtet in einem ganz starken
aufklärerischen sinne und in der
aufklärung liegt ein pädagogischer
impetus liegt nämlich auch das ideal
drin dass das menschengeschlecht zum
besseren erzielbar sei weil und das muss
man sich wirklich vor augen halten also
ich gucke jetzt nicht in dieser runde
aber generell noch mal in die runde
guckt das menschengeschlecht ist
möglicherweise verbesserungswürdig und
von dem herd die aufklärung hat diese
idee dass durch mehr bildung durch mehr
information durch mehr wissen aber auch
durch richtig verpacktes wissen durch
die richtige art dir ist den richtigen
tonfall dieses menschengeschlecht sie
vielleicht auch auf eine höhere stufe
zivilisation begeben könnte und darum
ist natürlich in sowas wie einem
aufklärerischen gedanken immer auch ein
pädagogischer gedanke drin und das kann
man jetzt grundlegend ablehnen aber ich
würde die aufklärung erst mal noch nicht
ganz aus dem fenster werfen
ich muss noch einmal auf ihre frage
zurückkommen weshalb ist alles cool
schlicht oder weshalb ist es eben nicht
gut da muss ich sagen herr bolz das
kommt er einfach wahnsinnig nicht statt
sondern medien fern vor wie sie nun die
situation und die arbeitsweise des
heutigen journalismus schildern
die leute die sie nun auf dem feld
abrackern
die machen wirklich andere erfahrungen
und das ist die nun seit zehn jahre
andauernden ganz massiven medienkrise
die schweiz hat in diesem zeitraum etwa
ein viertel der titel und ein drittel
ihres journalistischen personals
verloren das sind absolut dramatische
struktur verschiebungen und wir sind
wahrscheinlich erst am anfang die ein
zurzeit gerade die zusammenlegung der
regionalmedien was ein großer teil der
gruppen ist mit den medien bekannt
gegeben der tages anzeiger also die
tamedia hat die fundamentalste
strukturveränderung zur kostenersparnis
es überhaupt je gegeben habe bekannt
gegeben uns erwarte ich muss das nicht
alles herum es ist ringsum apokalyptisch
und bin ich zu ende noch ein punkt wenn
sie mit irgendeiner schwarzen regierung
aus dass der regierungsrat sprechen also
einem ländlichen gebiet und auch ich tue
das manchmal of the record nach
spätestens zwei minuten werden sagen wir
haben ein fundamentales problem wir
können mit unseren bürgern nicht mehr
adäquat kommunizieren
wir haben nicht mehr die adäquaten
kanäle das sind schon wir sind schon es
geht gar nicht mehr um die qualität der
demokratischen debatten es geht um ganz
simple sachen wenn einen die zahlen bei
auf der ebene der grundversorgung haben
wir ein problem
und wie man dazu kommen kann zu sagen es
ist alles gut und wunderbar weiter markt
das regelt der mann scheint mir gut
jetzt sagen selbstverständlich findet
ein bereinigungsprozess start aber
wissen wir keine nostalgiker wir sagen
ja nicht so wie es vor 20 jahren war
muss es in zukunft sein weil das die
ideale welt war
es findet eine bereinigung statt es wird
qualitätsmedien geben es wird regionale
medien geben die leute werden immer noch
absolut gut informiert sein der
regierungsrat kann auch sonst auf der
website auf seiner eigenen website oder
was auch immer
kommunizieren daraufhin brachte keine
regionalblatt für mich ist das reine
nostalgie gut es würde ich gerne auf
diese krise der medien ein bisschen
genauer eingehen und ein element ist
tatsächlich der ökonomische druck der
zunimmt die werbeeinnahmen sinken die
leserzahlen die auflagenzahlen die
zuschauerzahlen sinken das weiß man
und das hat zu tun mit dem was man
gratis kultur nennt und in diesem moment
möchte ich gerne mal dazu meinem
publikum gehe normal von ihnen wissen ob
sie eigentlich für informationen
bezahlen
ab und zu ja ich hab kein abonnement ich
suche sehr gezielt aus und dann bezahlen
sie denn sie sehr gezielt aussuchen darf
ich fragen wie sie kaufe ich scheine ja
printmedien also die sonntagszeitung und
danach online die basler zeitung und
dann im fernsehen schaue ich zahle man
sagt ja immer irgendwie für alles direkt
und wenn sie sagen sie haben online die
zeit zum bezahlen sie dafür oder sie
gucken einfach in diesem fall nicht da
habe ich keinen zutritt gratis zu dritt
aber die sonntagszeitung die zahl und
die bühne gehen wir hier mal noch zu
ganz jungen menschen nicht es da ihnen
nein grundsätzlich zahl ich nicht für
die informationen ich benutze auch
online zeitungen oder das wäre sein um
die sagen grundsätzlich ist da also
sozusagen eine grundsatz haltung auch
dahinter oder einfach machen sie nicht
nein das ist keine kunst zeitung
behindert das mache ich einfach nicht
weil ich momentan nicht für nötig halte
und glauben sie sind trotzdem
hinreichend informiert wenn diese leute
da ihre arbeit nicht mehr machen könnten
wenn niemand bezahlt dann denken sie
gibt es neue modelle oder was denken sie
denn ich denke nicht dass ich noch
ausreichend informiert werde
niemand bezahlen würde aber ich denke
momentan bin ich ausreichend informiert
da eine gewisse finanzielle
unterstützung vom staat auch noch da ist
von den leuten die dafür bezahlen
aber wenn es nicht so wäre weil ich es
wahrscheinlich nicht wie sie zuletzt
noch farben wer ist denn das steht für
sie der start ist sind grundsätzlich die
institutionen die drei säulen vielleicht
nicht so zu sagen und die leute
hauptsächlich sie sind nicht die leute
doch auch aber ich noch nicht noch doch
da doch schon aber aber doch noch nicht
ganz
nächstes bei ihnen darf ich sie noch
fragen also ich habe zwei tageszeitungen
abonniert und ich genieße das sehr das
hat für mich etwas sehr sinnliches und
ich kann nicht auseinandersetzen ob ich
gleiche meinung bin oder nicht das ist
für mich immer noch hohe qualität ich
bin vielleicht ein bisschen altmodisch
aber ich liebe das sehr
darf ich sie fragen wenn sie jetzt dazu
gehört haben überzeugt sie das sind sie
der meinung ja eigentlich alles in
butter oder sind sie ihrer meinung
katastrophe vielleicht irgendwo in der
mitte und ich denke auch bei meinen
medien konsumieren ist auch also ich
konnte mir sehr viel öffentlich
rechtliches öffentlich rechtliche medien
aber auch andere immer wieder mal
probeabos um ein bisschen so aller
seiten mit zu kriegen
ja aber ich denke es ist sehr gut dass
man über das öffentlich-rechtliche über
die öffentlich rechtlichen medien
spricht dass man das jetzt auch wieder
auf den tisch gebracht hat danke sehr
sich da wir haben hier eine ganz breite
palette vielleicht so ungefähr ein
abbild wie viele leute denken aber
tatsache ist diese zahl mentalität
sozusagen die nimmt ab es ist mehr eine
gratis kultur
die kommt eigentlich haben sie sich für
die gratiskultur ein bisschen
ausgesprochen habe
finde ich auch richtig so es ist eine
frage der intelligenz junger leute zu
überlegen wie man durch zusatzangebote
trotzdem geld kriegt das ist so alt wie
die internetkultur selbst also erst wird
alles kostenlos gegeben und verschenkt
und dann gibt es spezialangebote die
teuer sind und wo man interesse hat
spezial interessanten dafür zahlt man
ist auch bereit
zu zahlen also insofern finde ich das
richtig ich würde gerne von etwas
größeren hintergrund betrachten und
meinen optimismus so begründen dass ich
sage das gute an der sache ist
das fernsehen wird immer irrelevanter
innerhalb der gesellschaft und auch die
klassische presse das werden sie nicht
gerne hören aber auch die klassische
presse wird immer unwichtiger ich habe
es mit vergleichsweise intelligenten
leuten regelmäßig zu tun nämlich mit
meinen eigenen studenten von denen cook
niemand fernsehen also wenn ich versuche
über irgendeine sendung mal zu reden
oder auch nur über die tagesschau oder
irgendetwas niemand hat das gesehen auch
wenn 200 leute im vorlesungssaal sitzen
das heißt sie informieren sich alle über
ganz andere und das sind meistens
internetbasierte medien sowie auch er
ist das auf youtube richtigen die ganze
stellen wenn sie haben sie haben
vollkommen recht dass auch die
klassischen medien können sich im grunde
nur noch hinein retten
aber in dieser auf den neuen plattformen
in die soziale mitte und das halte ich
für eine sehr positive entwicklung weil
das die klassischen medien dazu zwingt
und zwar jedes klassische medium dazu
zwingt radikal darüber nachzudenken was
können wir was andere nicht können also
wo ist die unique selling proposition
unseres mediums etwa der klassischen
zeitung oder auch das fernsehen oder
wasser von marc-andre jetzt nur ich
meine ich natürlich ist es egal ob ich
etwas auf youtube schauer oder direkt
sozusagen um 10 vor 10 oder 10 18 auf
dem sender aber nein ich meine ich sehe
an diesem argument sich aber das problem
des finanzierungsmodells also wenn es
denn so ist dass wir das internet als
großen gratis raum wahrnehmen wo wir
alles gratis sehen können aber natürlich
sind die inhalte die da rein gestellt
werden und die dann zum beispiel in
diesen sozialen medien geteilt werden in
weitem umfang kommen die natürlich aus
klassischen medien und die braucht es
auch als es braucht einen gutbezahlten
journalisten der diese informationen
recherchiert hat damit danach ein
ordentlicher beitrag rauskommt und das
problem ist wir sehen ja wie facebook
wäre es wir haben jetzt unsere vision
ist zu glauben die journalisten würden
alle gut recherchieren und würden durch
die straßen laufen um kontakt zu den
bürgern zu gewinnen ich habe mir das mal
geguckt in beispiel beim bei der bild
-zeitung und bild online
die sitzen alle sowohl die klassischen
redakteure als auch die onlineredakteure
ununterbrochen vor bildschirmen also was
was wirklich beobachtet wird ist das
internet durch die journalisten die
journalistin studieren das internet und
gucken sich mal die nachrichtensendungen
dann kommt eine einblendung quelle
youtube oder so irgendetwas kein mensch
ist mir vor ort oder kaum mehr jemand
ist vor ort man überlässt alles
zunehmend und ist auch gezwungen das zu
ihren kunden ja ja ja ich habe hier eine
gute nachricht zu verkünden und ich kann
sie war die brücke schlagen zu meinem
papa und zwar wie folgt die zahl der
zahlenden kunden bereits derzeit wächst
und eigentlich ist das ja eine positive
entwicklung wenn im grunde genommen die
das medium konsumieren nach dafür
bezahlen selbstverständlich schwinden
die werbeeinnahmen und wir gehen davon
aus dass wir morgen eine zeitung machen
die ohne werbeeinnahmen
betriebswirtschaftlich funktionieren
können muss das heißt das risiko ist
diversifiziert die unabhängigkeit steigt
und gerade die das wäre die brücke
gerade die republik zeigt doch dass das
geld ist ja ein kunden finanziert
reinlesen finanziert selbstverständlich
ist das lesen eine elitäre veranstaltung
aber das schöne daran ist jede con
selber entscheiden ob er zu dieser lese
der elite gehört indem man nämlich liest
und die republik macht vor wie es geht
ja also es tut mir wirklich sehr leid
dass sie sich so befahl vorkommen nicht
an
sie sind noch ein relativ junger mann
aber bereits in varna so großartige
machtposition ich finde sie gern auch
ein bisschen selbstbewusstsein
aber was die republik anbelangt das ist
richtig nur löst das problem nicht
wir sind ein produkt der tatsache dieses
langsame zerfall der traditionellen
medienhäuser nur schon angefangen damit
dass wenn dieser phase nicht stattfinden
würde
dann wird
diese gruppe von teilweise sehr
gestandenen ex chefredaktoren und
anderen leuten die lange mit ihr gewesen
sind sich auf ein solches abenteuer
nicht einlaufen lassen
wir finden nun unseren kreis der leser
aber wir werden ein produkt bleiben wir
hoffen eine große nische zu besetzen
selbstverständlich wir auf einen großen
einfluss zu haben wir arbeiten daran
wir waren nie ein massenmedium sein das
ist apriori ausgeschlossen und das
problem die basis der massenmedien in
allen ländern waren lange zeit waren die
bürger seien die boulevard-zeitungen
hatten ein sehr tiefes niveau
aber sie hatten immer auch an politik
drin und auch eine politik teil es gabe
information es gab auf das alles etwas
hemdsärmelig und so weiter aber es war
durchaus auch eine information des
bürgers mitgegeben neben dem
zeitvertreib und dem tratsch und passt
alles auch noch waren ja sehr wichtige
funktion
wir haben eine starke substitution in
der schweiz in deutschland ist das
anders
der boulevard zeitungen durch die
gratiszeitung ja es einfach eine
verschiebung markt und die
gratiszeitungen haben fast gar keine
gehaltvoller informationen der boulevard
journalismus ist abgewischt
denn gerade des journalismus herbing
honda geraten schon alles das hat dass
vögel haben eine sehr sehr gute
empirische medien soziologie nicht die
funktion stelle
der öffentlichkeit und gesellschaft die
riesige quantitative studie machten
tagaus tagein und die auch einigermaßen
vernünftige qualitätsmessung kriterien
haben ganze halle einfach anzahl artikel
in den verschiedenen gruppen und sollte
und es zeigt sich einfach es hat ein
riesiger qualitätsverlust stattgefunden
also wir haben gratiskultur wir haben
leider in massenmedien aber der bürger
ist schlechter informiert und das ist
verständlich ein problem
nun gibt es natürlich auch lehrer und
lehrerinnen die sagen ihre schüler und
schülerinnen seien besser informiert als
früher weil nämlich alle auf dem weg zur
schule die entsprechenden gratiszeitung
informieren also die frage ist
wahrscheinlich auch noch wie definieren
wir genau informiert sein
also man kann ja heute auch nicht davon
ausgehen dass die bürger nicht
politisiert sein also wir leben ja in
hochpolitischen sein und das heißt die
leute sind ja sehr wohl informiert sie
können jetzt sagen sie sind nicht gut
informiert aber sie fühlen sich absolut
als politische akteure und das war vor
20 jahren anders
die meisten informierten sich über das
netz der zugang ist frei wir haben es
gehört deswegen wirklich betonen nein
wir haben kein problem
ich wäre gerne noch einmal auf das
ökonomische argument zurück gekommen
weil es gibt schon auch eine diskussion
die sagt es ist eine ich sag jetzt ganz
salopp eine berlusconisierung der medien
im gang auch in der schweiz auch in
deutschland die schwierigkeit dass
dadurch dass die öffentliche
finanzierung wird wegbricht oder gekürzt
wird oder dass man angst hat dass die
wegbricht dass immer mehr eigentlich
eben nicht der markt spielt sondern es
sind unternehmer die investieren die
sich einzelne zeitungen kaufen und
schlussendlich eben eigentlich politik
und medien viel stärker verzahnt werden
also genau das was sie kritisieren herr
bolz dass das eigentlich erst recht
geschieht wenn man das ganze den freien
markt überlässt dieses argument glaube
ich müssen wir schauen der freien markt
ist ein sehr großer markt und sie haben
eben die freiheit selber zu navigieren
ich würde damit geht ein ganz konkretes
beispiel nehmen wir eine prise berühmten
plattform twitter bisschen besser kennen
als die anderen
wenn sie was das einfachste von der welt
ist bei twitter mitmachen einfach wo sie
müssen ja gar keine eigenen tweets
machen einfach nur lesen
dann können sie sich ohne irgendwelchen
aufwand in ganz ganz kurzer zeit die
wichtigsten interessantesten artikel zu
allen möglichen themen zusammen holen
aber doch die doch zuerst einmal
recherchiert und geschrieben wurden aber
damit aber wäre ich aber wer
dahintersteckt ist ja einerseits dieser
artikel aber es gibt ja mittlerweile ein
riesengroßes her
andy hat man früher gesagt
bürgerjournalisten also leute die ich
meine das schmerzt natürlich die
professionellen journalisten dass die
bürger selber ihre eigenen kompetenzen
der eigenes wissen zu formulieren wissen
und auch tatsächlich einbringen
es gibt ein wunderbare und vielleicht
hätte ich das buch dann empfehlen sollen
da hätte ich auch ein buch gab
wunderbares buch von james zuruf jetzt
bewusstem of crowds also geht die
weisheit der menge und so jetzt gezeigt
sehr sehr schön dass nicht etwa wenn
sich massen treffen viele leute treffen
intelligenz entsteht sondern dass durch
ein intelligentes markt verfahren sowie
das friedrich von hayek schon sehr schön
analysiert hat intelligenz bilden kann
indem nämlich die unterschiedlichsten
menschen aus ihrem erfahrungs quellen
und aus ihren erfahrungswelten beiträge
leisten vor der finanzkrise erschienen
das ist überhaupt kein argument ist
verstimmt und versicherten ja wir haben
einfach gesehen diese dinge können
gründlich schief gehen ist es ging durch
bürgerjournalisten oder doch da lag im
westen das hat damit überhaupt nichts zu
tun wenn sie sollen jetzt gelesen haben
wissen sie genau es gibt eine sehr klare
definition dessen welche prozesse
ablaufen müssen damit diese effekte
erzeugt werden und das sind effekte die
man im internet hervorragend ab das ist
es worauf reichsburg dass diese diese
effekte eintreten weil ich meine es gibt
natürlich auch gegenteilige
untersuchungen die eben zeigen dass das
sich in solchen
medien in solchen sozialen medien ihr
die art so eine art von grüppchen und
und uns in seiten bildung verstärkt und
auch es gibt diese echo kam ein effekt
ist vollkommen klar
jetzt krieg ich auch so und das haube
des volkes langen meinungen die man
schon mal hart weil sie eben sozusagen
dauerhaft bestätigt werden weil die
auswahl lehrer denen ich folge natürlich
auch eine spezielle ist sich dann auch
weiter radikalisieren
die wahrnehmung rené heilig durchaus mit
in der scheuer sich teile durchaus die
wahrnehmung dass die bürger heutzutage
politisiert sind aber doch in einem maße
also in dem wir eigentlich wieder sorge
haben müssen wo sind die medien die
vermitteln also wo ist dieses
öffentliche forum wo man aus den
gegenseitigen schützengräben wieder mal
kurz hervor steigen kann und auf einer
gemeinsamen basis diskutieren das ist
doch das was uns abhanden kommt und
darum eben auch nochmal medien als als
öffentlicher ort und eben nicht als
einzelne kreise
das ist nur in einer dimension zu kurz
gedacht nämlich diese blasen oder diese
echo kann man bilden sich eben auch und
gerade in der öffentlichen kultur also
gerade auch in den klassischen medien
und gerade auch in der politik also ich
kann mir gar keine größere echo kamera
vorstellen als die regierungspolitik und
da gibt's das nur das ist fast eine
definition des leitenden politikers dass
er prinzipiell nur informationen
akzeptiert die seine eigene vorurteile
stärken und stützen das gehört fast zum
überleben eines politikers das wäre doch
sicher kein vorbild für aufklärung und
ähnliches passiert in den klassischen
medien
ich glaube sie müssen da mal eingreifen
sie können diese orte wahrscheinlich
einfach so stehen lassen oder naja
zunächst muss ich mal recht
[Applaus]
selbstverständlich hat der bürger schon
alles muss ein großes potenzial und wir
müssen alles daran setzen dass die
formen sich aus prägen wie kann das
besonders effektiv werden da ist sich
auch die tatsache der spontanen
entwicklung man sieht eben was sich da
alles ergeben wird die ist ganz wichtig
das ist ganz toll dass sie ein riesiges
potenzial ich glaube da sind wir uns
alle einig an dem tisch was wir auch
sehen ist dass es gewöhnlich schief
gehen kann
was wir momentan sehen ist das absolute
informations politische desaster von
facebook mit dingen die wir noch nicht
wissen die in allergrößte
geheimdienstliche manipulationen reichen
also zu sagen bürgerjournalismus ist die
zukunft und da das ist gut so einfach
sollten wir sonst nicht machen
und es ist ja immer so natürlich auch
eine regierung ist eine echo kammer auch
ein offizielles mediensystem ist eine
echo kammer wir sind immer im vorteil
strukturen gefangen das ist vollkommen
klar auch ein bisschen banal
die frage ist doch gibt es da sinnvoller
operative distinktion kriterien können
wir unser mediensystem denken indem man
sagt ja auch diese journalisten sind nur
menschen auch ihr verstand ist endlich
auch sie sind druckversuchen
manipulationsversuchen
beziehungs netzen ausgesetzt das alles
ist nicht objektiv aber vielleicht sind
sie doch ein bisschen op paris war da
werden wir als philosophischen kern
unserer der ganzen diskussion wenn man
nämlich überlegt wie wir das problem zu
lösen
und wenn man das organisatorisch nicht
lösen kann was ich allerdings glaube
könnte man es lösen durch etwas also
durch etwas wirklich philosophisches
nämlich indem man wieder akzeptiert dass
andere leute andere meinungen haben und
dass man die anderen meinungen nicht
verteufelt und ich glaube das wäre etwas
wird das gelingen würde also wenn wir
wieder ein klima schaffen könnten
diskussionsklima wo leute die anders
denken
meinetwegen trump wähler sind nicht des
teufels sind sondern einfach eine andere
meinung haben von der man sie vielleicht
abbringen
aber das argument das ja immer wieder
bringen woran genau machen sie das
eigentlich hätte sich doch irgend jemand
verteufelt sie können ja alle diese
dinge sagen was das ist allerdings der
letzte witz der in uns in der deutschen
diskussion immer wieder breit getreten
wird und das funktioniert nun allerdings
nicht an einem klassischen beispiel
mittlerweile schon klassischen können
sie das sehr gut deutlich machen
sarrazin immer dann wenn dieses thema
aufkommt sagt die öffentlichkeit wer die
veröffentlichte meinung ja aber sarrazin
da ist doch ein bestseller autor der
kann doch sagen was er will da hat
massenhaft publikum wenn der eine lesung
machtprobe sind brechend volle säle was
meckert der eigentlich was ist das für
ein leben wenn man polizeischutz braucht
was ist das für ein leben wenn man
ununterbrochen attackiert wird wenn es
die eigene familie bedroht wird nur weil
man eine meinung vertritt die nicht im
jahr sagen wir es ruhig roth wurden beim
swim entspricht ich würde sagen audi die
wirklich debatte mögen und andere
meinung die lesen das ist jetzt
sozusagen ein werbespot das volk herein
zeit aber ich komme auf ihre frage
zurück berlusconi rung berlusconisierung
der medien also ich denke ein
unternehmer der investiert der will geld
machen
das ist überhaupt nicht verwerflich
im gegenteil es ist die rede was will er
noch er will die besten journalisten
will ein gutes medium auch uns uns
verdient nämlich kein geld nehmen sie
diese sind die washington post
also sehe ich darin überhaupt kein
problem im gegenteil das ist einfach
eine form sozusagen der
marktwirtschaftlichen organisation es
gibt diesen player
es gibt den shooter die werke investiert
er viel geld machen oder weniger geld
machen absolut legitim das kommt super
medium sein
es gibt ja auch zehn gesellschaft es
gibt die genossenschaft und sprach den
wettbewerb aber player und wie aber ich
meine dass das dem kann man nur
zustimmen
die frage ist aber was wenn er mehr will
als geld machen was wir in der
politischen einfluss den willen gewinnen
will also berlusconisierung da ich meine
die anspielung auf berlusconi das geht
ja um weit mehr als um geld gegangen
aber seine zeitung also da wo wir vor
allem erfolgreich mit seinem privaten
fernseh formaten seine zeitung hat jetzt
das land nicht umgepflügt ich würde der
antworten die leser sind ja nicht blöd
also wenn die merken dass sie
manipuliert werden dass sie bevormundet
werden dann lösen sie kein abo und dann
ist die zeitung die relevant kann man
das heute wirklich noch so sagen in
zeiten von saic news die leser sind
nicht blöd das heißt nicht blöd sein es
ist nicht so trivial ist herauszufinden
wichtigste ich nicht so ist die
glaubwürdigkeit die glaubwürdigkeit der
quelle und das ist in diesem fall die
glaubwürdigkeit des medienhauses dann
wirklich schwer wir sehen hier in wir
sehen hier nehmen eben diesen
gescheitert ja und in basel gibt es die
bands und die bahn ist existiert hat hat
nicht funktioniert was wissen sie denn
was herr blocher wirklich wollte was wir
wissen ist dass unter seiner besitzer
schafft ja erst nach jahren offen
deklariert wurde auch das ein ganz
wichtiger punkt wir haben ja immer mehr
obskure besitzverhältnisse leute keine
klaren ansagen auf meinem ganz großes
problem er hat die leserschaft knapp
halbiert
eine absolute ökonomisches desaster
unter ökonomischen gesichtspunkten ist
markus somm eine der größten größten
plan größten pleiten der schweizer
presse geschichte wenn es was was die
reichweite
anbelangt aber ich glaube dass er seinen
auftrag sehr gut ausgeführt hat weil es
so haben politischer nicht und die frage
ist was machen wir seien milliardäre
über geballte mehr gemacht herr blocher
hat hier nun gerade ein gratis
zeitungsimperium zusammengekauft das
wird sehr interessant werden
es wird über geballte medienmacht sich
eben über die politische meinung
zusammen
ja ich würde genug er nicht ganz gewiss
sind jetzt rhetorische fragen was
befürchten sie konkret sehen sie es ist
nun aber die leute sind nicht blöd
sicherlich oder die leute sind
manipulierbar sonst würden macht affine
milliardäre nicht hunderte millionen in
zeitungen stecken sonst müsste sich herr
bolz auch nicht über die deutschen
staatsmedien aufregen medien haben am
fluss das ist ja das problem
es gibt sehr solide soziologische
studien auch beispielsweise der einfluss
von fox news in den usa
es gibt daneben prestigeträchtigsten
amerikanischen ökonomie channel
veröffentlicht mit ganz harten
statistiken die zeigen fox news hat die
präsidentschaftswahl 2002 2004
entschieden tramp charlie muir fox news
das ist ein problem aber jetzt kommt
zurück zum ball und herr murdoch hat
sich politische macht gekauft und es ist
nicht so dass er nur der vox populi ihre
impulse ab die laut stadt er hat das
amerikanische volk massiv vereins aber
seit ich wieder selber betreiben beiden
bleiben wir in der konfiguration
helvetica in basel wir sind ja hier in
basel führen dass in basel durch
was hier geschehen ist beweist doch
genau meine these also christoph blocher
hat irgendwas versucht wir wissen nicht
genau was die box war die post schreibt
zwar schwarze zahlen
aber sie steht wenn die
gerüchte stimmen auch zum verkauf das
beweist doch gerade die leser wollten
das nicht sie sind nicht blöd sie haben
die aber so abgestellt und das projekt
ist gescheitert
sie haben ja genau meine these bestätigt
er wollte die haben stärksten linke
start der schwarz drehen und das ist ihm
nicht gelungen das mit
manipulationsversuche nicht immer
gelingen
da haben sie recht die lese sie nicht
die sind echt nicht ich würde gerne
langsam zum schluss kommen und würde
gerne herrn boards und und frauen auch
zuletzt noch etwas sagen sie haben in
einem artikel in der nzz dadurch
scorpions erwähnt nämlich der autor von
generation ex und der sagt das beste was
wir tun können
der wirklich radikale akt ist sich
zurückzuziehen aus der medl wirklichkeit
und dann haben sie nicht überrascht weil
sie sagen nämlich das ist nicht die
lösung das ist nicht die lösung ist und
philosophisch die es um philosophische
in dem ursprünglichsten sinne dass
nämlich sokratis auf den markt gegangen
ist und nicht etwa in den wald und das
war klug und das war richtig und das war
zukunftsweisend
man muss sich tatsächlich und es ist
eine illusion das ist übrigens glaubt
ihr erstes wort heute gewesen was ich
richtig finde es ist eine illusion zu
glauben man könnte das sich aus der
mittel medien vermittelten wirklichkeit
zurückziehen
also dies den stecker ziehen das ist ja
dieses gab auch mal in linz glaube ich
vor jahrzehnten eine veranstaltung
dixies genauso ich ziehe den stecker
aber das ist eine illusion aber das ist
keine pflicht dazu bleiben nun ist die
frage ist ob distanz gewinnen kann zu
dem was einem zugemutet wird und
manipulation ist ein stichwort
propaganda ist ein stichwort dass wir
uns viel gezeigt alle wichtigen dinge
natürlich zu diskutieren aber natürlich
finde das ununterbrochen statt und es
gibt auch im continium wenn sie so
wollen zwischen von werbung public
relations und propaganda das geht
ineinander über und man kann sich dem
schwer entziehen
nur philosophie würde genau das bedeuten
oder wenn ein philosophischer impuls
würde genau darin bestehen hier distanz
aufzubauen also das ganze aus einer
größeren entfernung zu betrachten und
eben nicht mit zu mischen
also das ist etwas was man von
journalisten glaube ich nicht erwarten
darf das wäre zu viel verlangt
sagen würde haltet euch raus und
betrachtet euer geschäft von außen aber
die philosophen oder die wissenschaftler
die denkenden menschen sollten das tun
und eigentlich auch die kunden und wenn
so etwas passiert wie es geschildert
haben dann ist das ja tatsächlich so
dass die kunden die bürger die user doch
auch in der lage sind ein malen schritt
heraus zu treten und zu sehen was wird
ja eigentlich mit mir gemacht sie was
passiert ich jetzt noch immer ein großer
twitterer sind als das ist green sich
mitnichten zurück aber durchaus weniger
zum schluss gibt es eine
informationspflicht von seiten der
bürger ja natürlich und ich meine die
leser sind nicht blöd sie sind aber
trotzdem manipulierbar und darum ist das
so eine unendliche aufgabe und also
darum schwanke ich auch so zu diesem
optimismus und pessimismus ich meine
bernhard pörksen ist da ist der hat
diese art von sehr optimistischer utopie
dass wir in dem wir mehr in bildung
investieren was ja immer die prämisse
von allem ist das bild und ganz ganz
wichtig ist und wir es nicht
vernachlässigen aus den wahlkämpfen dass
wir tatsächlich in ihm sind eines
schulfaches im schönen einer
grundausbildung uns das aneignen müssten
das klassischerweise die journalistische
ausbildung ist nämlich dieses kritische
denken an der wahrheit orientierte
denken dass quellen prüfende denken
dieses nachdenken wenn da bei mir im
newsfeed was aufblitzt was irgendwie
sensationell klinkmann kurz überlegen
was ist das für eine quelle mal kurz
nach recherche und kann ist der user
also dieses unterscheidende kritische
denken kürzen sagt das ist eine aktion
elle gesehen ja eine konkrete utopie hat
so eine schöne utopie begriff er glaubt
auch nicht ganz daran aber letztlich
würde daran kein weg daran vorbeiführen
und insofern des utopisches und das
nicht ganz davon auszugehen ist dass wir
da ganz schnell dahinkommen liegt die
verantwortung wie ich fürchte doch nach
wie vor bei den medien machen
die sind am schluss unserer hunde wir
sind wieder einmal beim thema bildung
zuletzt die bildungshaus dann immer
jeden wir richten
ich bedanke mich ganz ganz herzlich für
diskutieren hier am tisch ihnen allen
frauenmagazins wanner herbolzheim vielen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und natürlich auch ihnen zu hause ganz
herzlichen dank für ihr interesse
nächste woche geht's ab nach irland
genau vor 20 jahren wurde das
karfreitagsabkommen auf der grünen insel
abgeschlossen das brachte dieser grünen
insel ein stückweit stabilität und
frieden jetzt mit dem raxit ist die
insel wieder ein bisschen in unruhige
rasen und es ist ein stück weit unklar
wie es da weitergeht wir zeigen ihnen
unsere gespräche die wir vor ein paar
monaten geführt haben
aus kilkenny belfast und dublin noch
einmal bis dahin kommen sie gut durch
die tage alles gute bis bald
[Applaus]
[Musik]